Salut ! Vendredi soir je vous ai mis un message sur les réseaux sociaux
pour vous proposer de refaire une vidéo Skype avec moi
en tout cas de tirer une personne au sort.
Et pour ça fallait répondre sur Facebook ou sur Twitter
Vous avez été nombreux, TROP nombreux, beaucoup trop nombreux à répondre !
Il va falloir que je trouve un autre système que les petits papiers
[rires] Là ça commence à être très compliqué !
La plupart d'entre vous, vous êtres déjà dedans
Là je suis en train de plier les derniers, la récolte du jour
[différents noms]
Il me reste encore tout ça à plier
et je procède...au tirage au sort !
Le pot est plein, j'appelle la main de l'innocence
MAIN DE L'INNOCENCE !
C'est parti !
[bruits de feuilles]
Je touille tant bien que mal, hein
Le résultat est :
Monsieur...J'écris tellement mal...
Monsieur Geoffrey Tastot
Tostot ou Tastot
Geoffrey Tastot je vais te contacter via Facebook
et j'espère que d'une, t'es disponible, et que deux t'as toujours envie de faire la vidéo !
Salut mec !
*Salut !*
T'as quel âge, Geoffrey ?
*20 ans, je viens juste d'avoir 20 ans il y a trois jours*
D'accord, bon anniversaire !
*Merci !*
C'est le cadeau d'anniversaire de Geoffrey
Quand tu me vois regarder là, c'est que je parle à tous ceux qui nous regardent
J'ai même mon café pour te dire à quel point je suis festif ce soir !
[rires]
Donc t'es à la fac, t'es dans quel coin ?
Ca fait un peu l'Ecole des fans !
"Et alors, tes parents sont là ?"
Je vais être obligé de faire comme ça pour que tu puisses voir ce que je fais
Donc on ne se verra plus, nous !
C'est pas grave ?
*C'est pas grave*
Il s'en fout complètement !
Vas-y, baisse l'écran, je veux plus te voir !
J'ai réfléchi à ce que je pouvais faire et je me suis dis, ah mec, j'ai envie d'un univers un peu particulier
et, il y a un mentaliste qui s'appelle Julien Labigne
et qui a sorti il y a pas mal de temps
toute une idée sur le thème du poker, et c'est ce que je vais te faire ce soir
Et dans cette boîte il y a pleins d'éléments qui se rapportent au jeu
Donc il y a un dé...
...il y a deux jetons de poker : un de 500 et un de 1000...
...il y a une boîte d'allumettes d'origine du Bellagio
une vraie de vraie
Il y a le fameux jeu de carte, évidemment
Tu vas avoir trois choix à faire, ce soir
Trois choix, c'est le hasard
Dans un premier temps, tu vas juste me désigner un des deux jetons
Ça c'est ta décision à toi
Tu me désigne ou le jeton de 500 ou le jeton de 1000
*Hum...500*
500 ? Ok, donc j'enlève le jeton de 1000
Je l'enlève ici, on garde que celui de 500
En même temps on peut se dire que t'avais une chance sur deux de le choisir, hein ?
donc on va compliquer la tâche, maintenant, avec le dé
Je t'aurais demandé de lancer un dé
Je te propose que ce soit moi qui le lance
et si le résultat te convient pas je le relance,
jusqu'à temps que ça te convienne, ça roule ?
*Oui*
Ok, ça c'est le hasard à l'état pur
Donc je lance...
Là ça tombe sur 5. Ça va ? On change ?
*On va changer*
On change, allez je relance...
6 ! Ça va ? On change ?
*On garde ça*
6 c'est bon ? 6 ça te va, OK
Donc on laisse le 6 ici.
Je vais faire un peu de place, d'ailleurs, pour qu'on y voit
500 et 6
Mais y avait que 1 chance sur 6 que je puisse avoir ça
Tu vois ?
Ou 1 chance sur 12, que je puisse avoir cette combinaison-là
On va rajouter maintenant un jeu de 52 cartes
OK ?
Ça c'est un jeu de 52, il y a un petit papier là derrière, je te ferai voir ça toute à l'heure
Un jeu de 52 cartes
Donc la fameuse carte blanche qu'il y a dans les paquets
Et ensuite le jeu complet,
je vais bien le mélanger devant toi que tu puisses bien voir
Attend, je me mets ici... Ça va tu vois bien ?
*Ouais ça va*
Cool ! [mélange de cartes]
OK, je le mélange aussi devant eux, si tu veux
Comme ça vous pouvez voir que je mélange aussi devant vous, y a pas de problème
Et maintenant, mon cher Geoffrey, je vais donner les cartes une par une
Quand tu te sentiras le moment, tu me diras STOP
D'accord ?
Quand tu voudras en fait
Quand tu voudras tu me diras STOP
J'en pose une
Deux
Trois
*STOP*
Déjà STOP ?
*Ouais*
Tu m'as stoppé sur la troisième carte ?
Direct ! OK, donc tu m'as stoppé sur le 7 de trèfle
D'accord
Une carte avant c'était le valet de trèfle, une carte après c'était l'as de pique
mais toi tu m'as stoppé sur la troisième carte : le 7 de trèfle
C'était hyper rapide
OK... donc 7 de trèfle
Et là y avait plus que 1 chance sur 52
Donc 1 chance sur 52 plus 1 chance sur 6 plus 1 chance sur 2
Et encore je devrais dire 1 chance sur 52 FOIS 1 chance sur 6 FOIS 1 chance sur 2
d'avoir cette combinaison là :
le jeton de 500, le 6 et le 7 de trèfle
Y a rien d'autre dans la boîte...
...y avait juste un petit carton que j'ai préparé ici à l'avance au départ
Je me suis dis, si tout se passe bien avec Geoffrey,
si tout se passe comme je veux,
si Las Vegas est avec moi
Alors
il choisira le 7 de trèfle,
le 6,
et le jeton de 500
Je leur fait voir à eux aussi
*c'est hallucinant* Le 7 de trèfle, le 6 et le jeton de 500
[rires]
*J'ai cru que j'allais te planter quand tu m'as dis "déjà"*
*quand j'ai dit la troisième carte, je me suis dit "là je lui ai fait un truc qui fallait pas"*
[rires]
C'est encore mieux que quand je reçoit quelqu'un à la maison.
C'est hyper stressant pour moi,
mais je trouve ça vraiment cool, en plus on peut se rencontrer
*C'est hallucinant...*
*En plus, avant de te découvrir, je faisais encore partie des sceptiques*
*vraiment, tout ce qui est mentalisme, j'y croyais pas du tout, mais là...*
*d'y avoir participé c'est troublant !*
Ah bah oui c'est sûr ouais
surtout quand t'as des doutes au départ et quand tu le fais...
Si cette vidéo ensemble vous a plu
vous pouvez nous le faire savoir et à Geoffrey et à moi, en laissant un petit
pouce en l'air !
Vous pouvez également commenter
Je lis tous les commentaires, j'y réponds
j'y réponds des fois que en fin de semaine mais j'y répond toujours
Vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne
parce que le MENTALVLOG c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez-vous demain, à 17H... CIAO !